panel highlights many social movements
and author Greg juban leads talks about
his book when we fight we win
is our first event in Brooklyn of 2016
so we're off to a good start I would say
so while you are here please feel free
to take advantage of both sides of this
partnership Busboys and poets will have
servers coming around the whole night
you can order food drinks it makes it
kind of a fun atmosphere and then at the
end there will be a book signing
obviously we're here because of a book
so our authors will be sitting up front
here signing and then you can grab a
book from here and just pay for it at
the bookstore on the way out a lovely
guy named Joe out there would be happy
to sell it to you so thank you again for
being here if you can take a minute and
turn off your and silence your
cellphone's we'd hate for them to be
buzzed all that stuff and then the other
sort of point of order you probably
noticed that c-span is filming tonight
so all of our presenters are going to be
speaking into this microphone so they
can get recorded and then during the Q&A
I'm gonna be walking around with a
wireless mic and they're gonna be sort
of helping follow that so that we can
get your questions recorded too so
please help us out by speaking into a
microphone at that point and then at the
end there will be like I said a book
signing and that'll be right up front
here so I think that's all the sort of
housekeeping points tonight we are so so
excited to have Gregg Jobin leads here
with a whole bunch of other contributors
and and people who have added really
wonderful things to this book when we
fight we win Gregg is a longtime
activist and sort of helped put this
collaboration together we have artists
we have other activists from all sorts
of social movements including black
lives matter
climate change marriage equality livable
wage and a whole bunch of other
socio-political initiatives that are so
so important and are happening right now
I'm gonna let him tell you more about
all the people who are here with him
tonight but it should be really a
fascinating discussion there's going to
be a performance as well and he is going
to tell you sort of more about all of
that that's happening the book if you
haven't seen it yet please check it out
it's beautiful there is art there are
people's personal store
there are all kinds of things in this
book tons of great interviews it is not
to be missed so we are so thrilled to
have them here for the launch of this
book please welcome Greg Jobe and leads
[Applause]
good evening
alright so before I get started I just
want to take a moment to take a moment
to ground us where we are and just want
to take a moment maybe I read can I take
a breath and bring in all your elders
the people who who's on on whose
shoulders you stand and you know for me
I'm thinking especially as this weekend
comes up think about Martin Luther King
think about my father
so I'm sorry I'm I want to start with
the ancestors I'm coming to elders in
that in a minute I want to start with
your ancestors all the people who have
come before us and social movements on
whose shoulders we stand so just take a
moment take a breath in bring in your
elders your ancestors excuse me
and then take a moment and bring in our
elders I think about my mother
Lila Leeds think about some of the
elders who are in the book Antonia
they're there so take them home and just
bring all those people in and then take
a moment to bring in your peers appears
here in Washington appears in the book
peers across the country and peers
across the globe we're all part of this
global movement that when we fight we
win is a small slice of and then let's
take a minute to bring in our young the
next generation and the generations to
come and then a moment to go in the
direction of the sky and whatever that
means to you some people call it your
Creator some call it God some call it
eternity so take a moment in bringing
the sky
and then I want to take a moment to
bring in the ground if you can feel the
ground through the concrete and the
earth and the mother and we've been
doing these six directions as part of a
ritual and one of the things we find
about so transformative social movements
is there is a element of ritual that is
part of all movements I'll tell you a
little bit about how things are gonna go
tonight
again thank you Abbey for welcoming us
and setting this up we have I'm going to
start off with a five minute interview
overview of the book and then we're
gonna have a wall and a who's designed
the art in this book who I'll give a
shout out for day in a minute but the
date day will be showing the slides
behind that then we have ray Kerry from
the National LGBTQ task force who will
be who will be speaking and heard her
story is the first story in the book
that and and her story in this
incredible way weaves together all the
other stories and then we have a
Jonathan Smith from the Alliance for
educational justice
we have suma arias with the Center for
Community Change and Rob s Priya with
Casa we'll be talking about the
immigration movement will have NAFTA
Freeman from pan-african community
action and the Institute for Policy
Studies is going to talk about the
prison justice movement and then we're
gonna I'm going to turn it over to Keith
art day who are the artists who designed
and who really are the brilliance behind
this book and we can turn it over to
them they're going to talk and give a
little little show and we'll have a Q&A
after that okay
all right so let's give one shout out
for de and Jorge who this is if you
haven't felt the book it feels beautiful
the art in it is absolutely stunning it
is remarkable it is absolutely the
brilliant artistic work of de Hernandez
and Jorge Diaz and AH he thought they'd
I've worked with a heath art day for
about 20 years now and anything they
touch turns to beauty it is absolutely
incredible out of the darkest moments
they they grow flowers and it is really
amazing all right how many people in
this room are actively involved right
now in social movements that is amazing
that is amazing because when we fight we
win has been a journey of amazing people
like you
it's full of the wisdom and the art and
the images of people like you who are
leading the campaign to game change
America all the royalties in the book
are gonna go to the art and the
organizations that are here all the
royalties go to there anything you buy
here it's a non-profit publisher
everything goes into nonprofits or this
local bookstore so it's really great
alright so the title when we fight we
win was a rally cry first heard by Jorge
Jorge Diaz my other co-author at the
anti-eviction campaigns of city life in
Boston banks were foreclosing on
homeowners but city life was able to
keep many families in their home city
life says we don't always win but we but
we win every time the right to fight we
win our humanity and if you don't fight
we lose when we fight we win highlights
what activists are doing to change the
horrific police brutality and deep
racism in this country the us used to be
the world leader in high school graduate
rates today where the world leader in
jails as an activist and a teacher for
more than 30 years I like so many of you
have watched as things have gotten worse
and worse the leaders in when we fight
we wind show us how to be better allies
to those on the front lines of the
struggle and they show us how to speak
out effectively and how to transform her
society as we stand at this very scary
but pivotal moment in history when we
fight we win documents how US
Immigration Police are raiding homes in
the dead of night children the elderly
sent to deportation camps families torn
apart deportations it reminds me of my
parents my and my brother Dan here who's
here tonight my parents watching
relatives rounded up for deportation and
Nazi Germany I am alive and Dan is a lie
because some people spoke up but not
enough not enough people spoke out about
the brutality then and that's why that I
know now to be silent is to collaborate
and why have to say we have to listen up
and we have to speak out when we fight
we win is filled with the voices of
moving activists and artists and
ordinary people who are not
collaborating and who are making
progress one of them is Patrice couloirs
bring out she's founder a black lives
matter
her brother was arrested and tortured in
the LA jails starved and dehydrated he
had to drink the water out of his toilet
bowl
Patrice tells the story of how she
formed the LA coalition to end shares
violence and how they won civilian
oversight over the LA Sheriff's
Department when we fight when we fight
this piece of art is done by Kevin
Rashid Johnson he's been solitary
confinement for 17 years not seeing
another soul for 23 hours a day when we
interview him he has to write us his
answers in pencil his powerful art hat
became the symbol of the 30,000
California prisoners who went out
hunger-strike Patrice and others in the
movement work to spread their message
exposing the horrific use of solitaire
and this year the prisoners won a major
policy victory in the chain and change
in the broad use of policy first in
California and now in New York when we
fight while prison activists and black
lives matter work to create these
changes they put forth amazing brilliant
visions and show us how to get there the
movements of today are game-changing and
interconnected Steve Meacham a movement
organizer at City Life helps lead
successful campaigns to keep people in
their homes and they do it by creating
and eviction
free zones how without he thought they
might co-authors they developed Street
Theatre and signs to tell their story
using lawyers quarters and by building a
human wall of hundreds of people
standing in solidarity they stop banks
from foreclosing on people and families
and they keep them in their home and
they changed local state and federal
policy this is one reason why at city
life they declare when we fight
well Lena Helms Hernandez and song
Southerners on new ground worked in
North Carolina to stop an anti queer
defense of marriage bill they lost but
while fighting they worked with queer
immigrant youth and they told their
stories about the horrors of the
deportation camps and the widespread
discrimination they faced the dreamers
as these young activists became known as
marched with t-shirts and that said
undocumented unafraid they defied the
immigration police and they occupy
President Obama's campaign office Oh
Obama's re-election campaign office and
this is finally what gets the President
to fulfill his earlier promises his
campaign promises when you fight there
are many other game-changing and
interconnected movements in when we
fight we win indigenous groups blocking
the tar sands and fracking Occupy Wall
Street 350.org the Chicago Teachers
Union the
truant workers fighting for a liberal
wage and many more together these brave
souls tell the story of today's
transformation I end with four of their
qualities that make it so when we do
fight we do in number one tell your
story
number two transformation only comes
with visions of transformation personal
transformation organizational
transformation cultural transformation
and political transformation okay number
three work in solidarity connect your
struggle and that to others we all need
to listen up and speak out and number
four disrupt the power change who has
the power and how power is held because
when we fight thank you okay next up I
have the amazing honor to welcome ray
Kerry who's head of the National LGBTQ
Task Force and who's just has this
gorgeous story in the book and I so
looking forward to being with you now
thanks ray thank you thank you Greg this
is gonna be a crying night I can tell
I'm ray and I had the joy and the honor
of talking to Greg over a period of
months to tell a story which is really a
series of stories in this incredible
book and I'm not gonna tell everything
that we said in the book because then
you wouldn't buy it you got to buy the
book but I but I do want to say I love
the title for the chapter that is about
the struggle for LGBT justice and
equality the title of the chapter isn't
how we won marriage equality
it's reclaiming wholeness and both parts
of that are so critical to our movement
right now
yes the last decade has been incredible
in the work that we have done to win
marriage equality but the reclaiming
wholeness is really about reminding the
country reminding our own movement that
the answer to the question of what's
next after winning on one issue that's
important to some people is the same
thing we've been working on for the last
60 years economic justice social justice
racial justice so I will tell you that I
came out when I was 16 years old in
Denver Colorado and I thought sweet I'm
exempt I don't have to get married I
don't have to get kids right that was
the story then in the 80s and I I
mentioned that because what I didn't
realize I was doing was internalizing
the oppression and a lack of equality at
the time around relationships and around
love which as a lesbian is important and
the reclaiming of wholeness for any one
of us is to understand that you can't be
a lesbian one day and a mom the next and
latina the next or you know whatever all
the parts are of our whole selves and so
when we talk in the book about
reclaiming wholeness it is about seeing
the interconnectedness of our lives and
the joy of seeing this book come to
fruition is that it's not just a book
certainly and it's an inspiration it's
something that anytime a staff member of
ours or volunteers having a hard day I'm
gonna hand them a copy of it and say
flip to any page flip to any page and
just read what's on it because the book
itself is about wholeness it's about the
insistence that we are humans that we
cannot be divided up that we will come
together to work for social change and
it is such a joy that you and others
around the country will be a part of
this there's something at the very end
of the book mention of Vincent Harding
who I have had the honor to know in my
life he's passed now but he talks about
the river of struggle and what I love
about the inclusion of the river of
struggle is that water never stops
flowing
it never stops flowing and a river is
made up of so many tributaries of so
many drops of water and even when a log
falls in the way the water figures out a
way to keep flowing and so I'm gonna
take from the experience of this book
and learning from people around the
country who are doing the work for
change that we've got to keep flowing
and I would say in joining us from the
LGBTQ perspective the lesbian gay
bisexual transgender and queer
perspective how I would ask you to join
if you aren't if you don't identify in
that way in solidarity is to insist that
we are all whole people that
reproductive rights is an LGBTQ issue
that immigrant rights is an LGBTQ issue
that prison reform is an LGBTQ issue
that police brutality is an LGBT issue
that all of these issues are issues that
affect our lives as a whole so I invite
you tonight to listen to our other
friends here
and take in how you are part of the
wholeness of this book and thank you for
this gift thank you
[Applause]
thanks ray
okay so next up we have Jonathan stick
stiff from the Alliance red educational
justice education is the movement that's
closest to my heart and has been and
I've been teacher and I'm just so
thrilled that Jonathan was able to be
with us thank you I liked him at least
my poem called creamy gosh so I don't
know if so the story about Chicago is is
one of immense possibility and I had the
opportunity to work and walk with jitu
Brown in that story and I don't know if
you've ever walked with a madman and a
madman who dared to invent a future and
every time g2 has an idea he has a way
of well brothers and sisters and he gets
us going and then after the meeting I'm
always loved with how the hell we gonna
pull this off and so I walk into the
story in 2012 although Chicago was the
epicenter of masses of privatization and
school closings and state violence it
was also happening in New York City
Philadelphia and Washington DC and so
part of our struggle he's he got us
we're at a meeting and he said well why
we here this meeting we need to go down
downtown Chicago an hour away to drop
off some title six complaints to the
Department of Justice and I said how
long give 50 high high school students
to Chicago and so we figured out a
caravan of camps we've been through a
Chicago rush hour to get to deliver
these letters and from that journey for
justice was born and this movement to
fight school closings our work before
then was around ending the school to
Prison Pipeline and really understanding
school discipline and a negative impact
and for us our work has then now been
how do we understand the two and so for
us the mo the movement and the moment of
black lives matter offered us an
opportunity to talk about state violence
and to understand what's happening in
our schools both through school closings
and the school to Prison Pipeline as
state violence as violence as government
power there hurts government power that
harm
that the education that young people of
color receiving in this country is a is
an education that teaches them their
place and it's not it's not lost that
it's called the school to Prison
Pipeline and so where I work now moves
forward it is it's beginning to think
about what next and so for us and the
young people in the folk who do it we
have this vision of Education being for
liberation and so for us the work that
happened and diet the diet hunger
strikers before there was a diet well
there was the diet 13 and now was the 13
high school students who showed up to a
school that was supposed to be closed
demanding an education we've also begin
to understand what's happening in the
United States has an international
crisis that we've linked with brothers
and sisters in Brazil as well as South
Africa to understand again with the what
we are now calling educational
colonialism what we know as charters and
privatization is an international
movement and we'll take those an
international movement if we're going to
liberate education and then our last
piece in in bridging what we also learn
from the movement for black lives matter
was the 1033 program and I think this is
where my request is is that when we
found out Ferguson that the guns in the
tanks that the police department had we
found out that they had them in LA and
an LA school police department and that
25 other cities across the country are
receiving government grade weapons for
schools and so we begin to ask the
question if we're familiar with the
history of Salado and 76 we have to ask
some very serious questions who are the
guns for who are you planning on
shooting and so and then we have to ask
the same question to a federal
government that denounces a school to
Prison Pipeline but continues to fund it
and so we see students at the table
arguing arguing for 50 million dollars
of restorative justice while the same
federal government gives 250 million
dollars for police and all the free guns
that they want and so if we are really
going to liberate education if black
lives are to matter but all of our lives
don't matter then our first step is
calling on the federal government to
intent the 1033 program of police out of
schools thank you and when we fight
[Applause]
thanks Jonathan and if anybody here
doesn't know about diet that's a great
story in the book alright so next up we
have for the speaking about our
immigrant brothers and sisters Summa
aureus with the Center for Community
Change and Rob s Priya
Robespierre with Casa thank you and good
evening
so I am super audience and thank you
Greg it's a pleasure to be here I want
to start out by so the the the book
begins in with with a great fight an
inspiring fight by amazing young people
called the the dreamers that begins in
2010 where they fight and they win
because when we fight we were and so it
takes us it begins in 2010 and then it
takes us 2000 to 2012 when something
that could not be done to give millions
of young people the opportunity to go to
school to pay taxes and to leave without
fear in this country was finally given
in June of 2012 and then it takes us
from that fight to another fight and
it's the fight to save our parents this
fight is for 11 million undocumented
immigrants in this country and we're
still there we're still in the fight and
it Atlanta it ends in 2014 where after
we were told we couldn't win and the
president could not give us executive
action we found that in 2002 in June of
2012 that that wasn't true because we
fought and we won then again another
victory when we were told he couldn't be
done in 2014 after sit-ins and fast and
arrests
in 2000 November of 2014 we again won
the the right for parents of children
who were born here in this country to
stay but the amazing thing and where we
find ourselves today after two years and
and Rob will share a little bit more
about that is that on this day today we
have begun the year two years later with
raids with hate and with Trump hate and
again we are beginning we're in this
fight similar to 2010 where we are we
are the victory that we had in 2000 in
November of 2000 2000 14 when we finally
so the many years of fighting and and
many of us add in living rooms are
watching the announcement of the the
protection of millions of families only
to find out as we were transitioning
into 2015 that the state of Texas plus
26 other states filed a lawsuit against
the United States that would prevent
that executive action for from being
implemented so the last year we've spent
fighting
we've spent fasting we have spent
looking still to win an event and
eventually get to the to the Supreme
Court to actually give us what we
rightfully won by fighting so it's
interesting that we find ourselves this
week this Friday with that in that fight
thank you so much my name is Rob esprit
I'm only organized for Casa and Casas
are one of the largest human rights
organizations in the country we have
about 80,000 members and right now we
find ourselves in a fight for our lives
literally in the immigration oftentimes
people think of immigration and if they
see the image of a Central American well
what we don't see is that immigrants are
from all over the world
they're from West Africa they're from
Asia from Europe they're from all of the
world so a cos I had the opportunity to
work with some outstanding leaders
Phyllis Carl outcomes of mind he's a
West African immigrant that he
said this Friday last Friday at the
White House in the morning he said to
press into and and to all it would hear
him he said right now you're going out
to Central Americans but I know that
you're gonna even you're going after me
next so he knows that today Central
Americans tomorrow its West Africans in
near future it's Asians and so this
struggle is all of our struggles and
I've got the opportunity I have the
opportunity to work with leaders like
Miguel kleros from Bolivia Maya
Ledesma from Mexico these are leaders
that have been have been arrested for
civil disobedience and they themselves
are undocumented and but they still go
forward and and brave and put their
bodies on behalf of the struggle and so
I ask you guys that are here to join us
this Friday because we'll be at the
Supreme Court at 11:00 a.m. and and I'll
pass some flyers and sometimes I'm an
organizer before I leave this thing
because when we fight we win so thank
you guys so much for this opportunity to
talk to you thank you you know I got to
tell you when I first heard the dreamer
stories and they talked about the ice
raids and these vans coming at the dead
of night and sweeping up families I had
these chills as I was hearing because it
reminded me of those same stories that
my my parents would tell and my father
was the last Jew in his high school in
in in in Hamburg Germany and so I really
appreciate you the story and also you
telling that story Robert about the that
you know I know first they're going to
come for for the Central Americans but
but who's next and there's some famous
quotes in the book that many of you will
remember okay next up we have net feh
Freeman who's from the pan-african
community action and the Institute for
Policy Studies and I got to say about
the prison
in Chapter it was my scariest to
research and write and it was the most
beautiful in its transformative visions
that it's absolutely mind-blowing so
thanks so much for being here thank you
and thanks for coming here I guess I
should say in terms of my relationship
to this chapter and what it talks about
mass incarceration is another
affiliation that I didn't put his family
and friends of incarcerated people and
chapter 3 which talks about the
transforming of vision and I think it
also speaks to a lot of what previous
speakers have talked about the small
victories along the way which are
protracted and which are not necessarily
this big win that we see but a lot of it
transforming vision means to me and what
the chapter speaks to is also a common a
lot of what Jonathan said which I've
worked with the years especially when
you're talking about the school to
Prison Pipeline it's talks a lot about
the school to Prison Pipeline has has
been cultivating ideas cultivating a
vision and understanding one in
particular around this is the
interconnectedness of an interrelation
of the school to Prison Pipeline massive
car serration and police brutality the
black lives matter movement how all of
this is a reflection of the need for the
system and the society to control us and
also speaks to and we concede now with
the black lives matter movement and
understanding of the interrelationship
between all of this that we may not have
seen before which a lot of times before
we were seeing the movements looking at
dealing with approaching different
issues in a siloed sort of way oh I'm
working on education and prison the
pipeline sources I'm working on the
prison industrial complex and then
priests brutality over here which now
where people are looking at it has a
much more holistic thing so when we
engage and a protracted struggle also a
protracted part of that struggle being
the transformation of our understanding
our ideas it is a fight and when we
fight so right now I want to say that a
part of I just want to really quickly
touch on starting with work with the
family and friends of a car serated
people and other transformation of the
of the idea
is a family in front of across rated
people besides myself
there's primarily brothers and sisters
brothers who were formerly incarcerated
right it's actually an organization that
started in prison by those who are
incarcerated and deals with the fact the
children mostly the children of those
who are affected by mass incarceration
in some way one of the things we're
seeing now particularly in the movement
that we may not have seen as much before
is a respect and a buttressing of agency
of the most impacted the oppressed in
other words those who are most impacted
by the the social conditions the social
ills that plague us they should be at
the forefront of the solutions and
organizing around it so much of for what
have been done before has been to do
things for people and to provide and
whatnot but now we're seeing that people
are respecting those who are most
impacted by someone should be by a thing
should be the leaders of that thing
pan-african Community Action is a
reflection of that so we can just very
quickly - and it's a new organization
it's arisen out of the need for us seen
that the community most impacted by
police brutality particularly is arising
out of the murder of Alonso Smith who
was a young Virginia school teacher and
DC resident he was murdered by the
special police special police private
police right who have obviously it seems
more powers than regular police so we
began organizing around the issue of of
community I mean grassroots community
power and the main objective is
community control of the police many
people I don't know how many people have
heard of this concept usually we hear
community review boards and community
policing but we're talking about the
community actually having power over
those who are charged or you know give
sanctions to come into our community be
armed arrest us and evidently kill us so
if if those people are charged to do
that it's only our democratic and our
human right to have control over who's
hard to do that what their
responsibilities are this is a new it's
actually not a new concept it's a
concept that started some time before
particularly if we look at the we charge
we charge genocide and the Black
Panthers were organizing around
community control the police
so much and I'm gonna get to one last
thing as of the how ideas where ideas
come from so much has been done to to
take us away from the the solutions and
the things we fight for it would
actually transform our lives so the
community control of police of like a
whole lot of other things has been
intentionally put to the side so that
people didn't understand it so the the
new generations that came up and fight
for and to fight for redress didn't know
that they were certain precedents
certain solutions and ideas that
preceded them that were actually
attainable now its resurfacing we're
hearing a lot more about community
control the police across the country
not just in Washington DC and it's
something that we can achieve not only
do we know how we can do it statutorily
we also are engaged in the community the
protracted work of community organizing
and building agency with those most
impacted then lastly I want to talk
about and then this is a not quite in
the book necessarily but it's part of
the work all of the work that's been
done that is covered in the book is
communications I'm also with WPF W radio
and we are seeing we've seen now with us
particularly with the rise of the
internet so many sophisticated and
creative means of disseminating
information to engaging people and
informing people of the struggles that
are affecting our lives before we could
also see saw that the media was mostly
controlled by those who oppress us now
we control a lot of the media and we're
finding ways to get our message out
there in a way that has had
unprecedented successes and so many ways
even keeping staving off the what is it
the into the internet thing the bill
that's trying to control net neutrality
thing so we can see that we've been able
to hold that where it's actually have
complete power to be able to do with
what they want but they haven't done it
what they want it because when we fight
[Applause]
alright and now we're now we're gonna
get to the good show of the night and
the artists who who made that make this
beautiful and will make the evening
beautiful so we're gonna end we're gonna
end with their show and we're running a
little late so there might be a moment
of Q&A but it might be tight so so Jorge
Diaz and de Hernandez from ah he thought
they that word cat is actually good
because I don't like to speak but I'm
just gonna go quickly
my invoke the book the book so I'm the
art curator and the director of and I'm
an artist Simon artists with heat our
day and I hate our day well basically
this book emerged from a long term more
than 20 years relationship between my
mentor and your friend and colleague
Jorge Diaz
and Greg gob leads so I was raised in
Puerto Rico and first time that I came
to the States to do work around
anti-eviction anti foreclosures and
evictions with city like Villa Juana
so I came to work directly with the
organization to develop some signs and
and then after that I started coming
back and forth doing work with the
organization and then ended up staying
in Boston and start and start working
with it with this particular project
heat arte it's an organization of
artists who are committed to create and
develop projects of cultural solidarity
and also supports cultural workers like
myself what else um coming to the book I
definitely wanted to introduce readers
to visionary artists who are committed
with their communities
and and also to to kind of like to
present the though all the work that
goes to culture work what a project is
the labor that goes to culture work
anything else I won't say I'm also a
puppeteer so I'm an architect by
training but I'm a puppeteer by heart so
basically I do a lot of puppets and I
work with paper I think that's it I just
want to share another thing that
recently just going back and forth with
the artists who are portrayed in the
book
I'm so very humbled and excited that the
reaction has been great I think that
pretty much the the the beautiful thing
about this book is that um it does have
a lot of work of artists that who are
not who are often unrecognized in media
and in the art scene also in political
also in our political circles so if I
want to say something it's also that the
importance of culture and art it to
build movement so definitely support
your artists and yeah well not no just
my name is Jorge Diaz I am the artistic
director of a hitherto
and I'm also a founding member of papel
Machida which is the radical street
theatre and puppetry group that they was
referring to we've we've been around for
10 years were based out of San Jose
Porto Rico that's what we do most of our
work and I say that also to say that we
are a diaspora project he TARTA has
worked for almost 20 years working with
communities of color black and brown
communities in Puerto Rico and in the US
and building those bridges understanding
the importance of us as a colony to be
able to build bridges with our oppressed
folks here in the United States and
build those relationships which I think
are very important and I feel very
honored to be around all these wonderful
people that stepped up here who also
belong to our frontline communities and
I want to specify that we're talking
about frontline communities because a
lot of people
the right-wing struggles as well and a
lot of time they seem to be winning they
fight and win - so I want to be clear
that we're talking about struggles
against imperialism we're talking about
struggles against white supremacy we're
talking about struggles I can spay
Turkey and I say that because Greg had a
great idea of calling this today the
state of the movement as Obama gives his
last speech which I will not forget his
inaugural speech
I usually don't listen to these things
but I was very he's a great speaker and
I wanted to see what he had to say and
not what a black president would say
coming into office I was really
interested and I one line that I will
never forget is one of his main lines
and it's like this typical US president
cowboy line it was we will not apologize
for a way of life and as somebody from
Puerto Rico as somebody from a
third-world country
economy of the u.s. that scared me
because I knew that what meant I'm sorry
I knew that that meant that we would
continue on this path of war against our
people that we continue on this path of
not having health care in this country
then we continue on this path of
criminalizing our young black and brown
men and boys and girls in our schools
and it would be also to continue this
path of the prison industrial complex I
did not know at the time that I also
feel an extreme right-wing white
supremacist groups and movement that now
we have to battle so today I hear
Obama's before his speech was talking
about this idea of unity that there's
this unity in the US and it's very
interesting something but sometimes we
throw this word around of unity where a
lot of times our movements have not been
about unity in the broad sense it's been
a unity of a couple folks unity of
organizers unity of militant folks who
are willing to take that chance and to
shift the culture to shift us away from
this idea of that we have to continue
this American Way of life so I invite
folks and I invite folks as a cultural
worker with another culture working next
to me and as you see the book that we
have a mission to try to shift this
culture
so that unity can mean and unity against
imperialism against white supremacy
against patriarchy a unity that for me
is in the best tradition of this country
of the wonderful people in this country
that have fought for it and I mean
fought for the rights that we now take
for granted or fought for the things
that we're losing but that we're still
here and that when we build that unity
on a shift of culture then we can really
get to a point where we can proclaim
what we can yell out in the best feeling
of liberation and freedom when we fight
we were cuando lucha Maz gamos
[Applause]
[Music]
it's almost like three theaters so it
takes a minute to set up usually before
I gotta buy before talking on this
happens
[Applause]
[Music]
como si todo en la vida de parte de
concepción la la la vista CA go vamos al
mundo Sami Khedira SEMA concepts yo
Thomas ooh descanse we go Eva SIA
I need no scheming today either SIA
I need yo scale mantaining SI yo soy de
los de bajo que tiene que man nothing
one is more better took every B see yo
soy de los the Abajo
Karen your thing what miss more than a
job a baby as if everything in life
failed her conception raises our gates
to the street protests where black lives
matter to end white supremacy because
this is persistent business pictures
storytelling about a complex system in
neutralized in the lies of our people in
prison
it's the prison doctor complex or p IC
which feeds of people of color or pee Oh
see
before the war on drugs got be clear
there were about two hundred and fifty
thousand inmates in the US prison nation
today us tales and prisons are filled
with over 2.4 million people between
1970 and
thousand five our presentation increased
seven hundred percent with over 50% of
our inmates in federal prisons in jail
for drug offenses and ten percent for
immigration related crimes this means
that these two categories of nonviolent
crimes comprise over 60 percent of the
federal prison population we bring this
will to you as a challenge to common
sense to the idea we have grown up and
left with that prison is the way to deal
with crime and the most affected by it
the poor if all prisoners are counted
including juvenile territorial eyes
Native American country military you
have has around 25 percent of the
world's prisoners even though it only
represents 5% of the world's population
Apple total population of inmates blacks
are incarcerated five times more than
whites and Latinos twice as likely any
percent of the incarcerated are
low-income and here is 40 percent of
time is attributed to poverty more black
men are in prison or jail or probation
or on girl
that were enslaved in 1860 and that's
why we asked this matter because we're
all created equal
why are so much more equal than others
since the 1970s and coinciding with the
drug war harsh punitive policies
mandatory prison sentences and three
strikes are odd laws multiply caprice
nation of the US some would say this is
good because criminals are behind bars
but if you look closely the Queen's
reveals an economic system based on the
needs of a chieftain Margaret lucrative
businesses that have turned surplus
working class people into natural
resources to feed a punitive any domain
capitalist system of Correction by
Forbes roughly 6% of fate prisoners and
16% of federal prisoners are
incarcerated by and works for private
companies the majority of employed
prisoners are paid between 12 cents to
40 cents an hour
prisoners have often being subjected to
dangerous working conditions such as
been exposed to tottenham and let while
recycling electronics geo group is one
but two billion Corrections Corporation
of America annual revenue is 1.7 billion
with eyes contracts with some 15,000
bets in 14 facilities these are two
largest of private person corporations
in the US and we thought I'd one warning
bottle POTUS so you find out of po-boy
you know maybe Gong Kato pork a corner
your story them their kid out there boy
some would say prison labor helps
inmates prepare for the labor market but
looking closely we see corporations
taking advantage
prisoners even if it makes our employee
why did it have to be exploited and why
why not pay them a living wage since
their families lose the income member of
that family the hype of maintaining
contact with family members in prison
leads more to more more than one in
three families into that which then goes
back to our youth American dreams of
upward mobility are also common sense to
us if we study hard and work hard we
will be rewarded we're supposed to be an
equal playing field in the land of
opportunity but reality is far from this
black and brown you and the schools are
being pipelined into prisons in the US
continues to have an excess of our
people not needed for manufacturing
anymore funnels into service jobs that
make it impossible to folks to even
leave in the neighborhoods where they
grew up and lived but some are not
followed even if they graduate and their
schools closed they are target's to be
policed intervened under protocol to be
murdered by the state's sweet deadly
force of less lethal weapons or full
please empty dr. our black and brown you
adults and elders one dojo Saturday
desta precio chemical to tomato - Ramiro
Russell CC Joaquin a local selling
christine taylor gray
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Brian Tracy
Tommy arrived and oka seven everything
in life failed her concepts young raised
our gaze to the street protests were
bloodless matter to end white supremacy
cuz this is resistance
thank you oh do y'all have a time check
to see if we have question answer time
what's the deal once two questions okay
one or two then anybody have a one or
two Wesley nope
and then see who what's it for that you
can also ask the specific person over
onto the group there's a whole group I
think when your United States was
originally founded there were very few
police departments mostly all the states
made sheriff's over each county in all
of those sheriffs I think in almost all
the states were elected by the people
today we have a situation where there's
hundreds of different police departments
offices like transportation police
heartfully they've got all these
different kinds of place like schooling
and they created State Police they're
creating these police departments and
none of them are very few of them are
have the police chief elected by the
people the sheriffs in all the states
were elected by the people if there was
police brutality the people could take
it off then sheriff and get rid of it
put another sheriff in there and that
would straighten up the problem but now
we have police departments where they're
appointed they're not elected by the
people or anybody trying to are there
any organizations trying to make more
accountability over the police by having
them there police chiefs be elected
[Music]
um well first I think they were
important there's a need to have
historical analysis of the first
policing and where police came from and
it goes all the way back to I mean back
to slavery it goes back to those who are
hired or or yet hired to be slave
patrols who are trying to keep control
of resurrections of their interactions
by slaves and what capture runaway
slaves these are first the first forms
of police in the south and the North the
first forms they were all private
agencies they weren't elected or
anything they were hired by capitalists
to control and protect their property
and in South it was slaves who are you
know people were the property enslaved
and the north it was the fact the
warehouses and whatnot they were private
you people heard of the Pinkerton agency
and these types of so these are the
earliest forms of police and it was
until we can go into a long about the
history and transformation of them but
what we have to understand is that
suffice it to say that the police are
here to maintain the status quo
those who best interests are served by
the status quo goes that's where the
police are controlled by I you know it's
more than just I think it takes more
than just electing I think it takes a
transformation of the entire system when
we transfer and transform the entire
system then we can talk about what forms
of security we need to secure what we
have created because it's not just about
um it's not just about reforming the
police it's about transforming the
system which police have been licensed
or whatever to protect
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Gregson's in here signing books my guess
is that none of the people who spoke
here are running out of the room so if
you have questions that you didn't want
to ask I'm betting that they're all
willing to stick around and talk to you
together Bucky we need to sort of start
a line going back from scratch analogy
bro
book TV continues now a Barry Lancer on
afterwards the criminologist tracked
violent crime in the United States from
the 1960s to today he's interviewed by
Samuel Beiler of the Urban Institute
with high profile spikes and violence in
Milwaukee Chicago Washington DC the
question in the issue of violent crime
has acquired a national salience that it
hasn't had since the 1990s berry lats a
professor emeritus at John Jay College
has written a new book the rise and fall
of violent crime in America Billy what
inspired you to reinvestigate the issue
of violent crime no one had really
studied in a comprehensive way